I understand how this individual mandate
is something that we've allowed the
Republicans to define as some sort of
Quantico government takeover in fact
it's their idea the progressives were
saying we want single-payer the
progressive myself I would say why do
you need insurance companies for
healthcare at all
insurance is what you buy when you don't
know if something bad is gonna happen
maybe I'll crash my car maybe I won't I
don't know so I'm going to get car
insurance just in case everybody's gonna
get sick and die so you know every
single person is gonna need out the
dress not it something get it prior to
charge before that's called a service so
my view single-payer the Republicans
always said no that's too much
government so we came back said okay no
no single-payer how about a public
option so you'd have a public program
everybody could join Medicare or compete
with the private companies too much
government we want individual
responsibility so we said fine you win
we'll do it your way
individual mandate and then they say
that is a socialist government takeover
well hold on a second now you're now a
part of the pro moocher caucus you're
saying it's okay for people just die
bomb their way into the emergency room
and don't worry about it don't get any
insurance the government will pay for it
you're like the like now you're like the
pro freeloader party this republican
party from my point of view it has taken
the posture that any idea even their own
ideas if they're championed by this
president they will oppose I think that
discredits them it's like chasing a
bunny on the old dog track they have a
mechanical bunny ever been to a dog
track I'm from Tennessee if you ever go
to Memphis they have a dog track and
they have a mechanical bunny and the
daily they open the gates and the dogs
just go and try and chase that
mechanical bunny and I think those dogs
probably think someday they're gonna
catch that bunny they're never gonna
catch that bunny because the bunny keeps
moving you're trying to chase the right
to try to convince them to agree with
you they will run away from their own
ideas if they
think a Democrat embraces them it was a
Republican idea to have cap-and-trade a
market-based business friendly solution
for cover for carbon and climate
problems that was a Heritage Foundation
came up with cap-and-trade we were
seeing carbon tax to chase them we moved
to cap-and-trade and they moved on to
don't do anything climate change isn't
even real on health care they it was
their idea to have an individual mandate
personal responsibility you don't have a
big government single-payer system we
moved from single-payer through public
option to individual mandate trying to
catch them and now the here are they say
that they digital mandate socialism you
will never catch this buddy you will
never know what you need to do is stand
for what you believe in and bring a
majority around your own ideas and
govern and it is the biggest fallacy on
the part of liberals is that that little
hound dog running around that track is
ever going to catch that Bunny and that
we will ever be able to compromise
enough to appease the right wing in this
country so they'll actually govern with
us in a responsible way they have to be
defeated at the ballot box by a stable
governing majority that can implement
the changes we need in this country
whether they want to participate or not
you